all right saw this movie now I need
Prozac out of the furnace side of the
furnace starts Christian Bale has a few
other people in it you can argue it
stars them also but this is Christian
Bale's movie I know that because he's
the one on the posters the reason he's
on the poster is because it's his movie
Christian Bale lives in this shitty part
of town or at least a shitty town in the
state or at least a shitty state inside
the United States I don't know the point
is you look at his surroundings and
you're like I don't ever want to end up
there ever but he's a hard-working guy
he works at the mill he busts his ass
for a living Casey Affleck says brother
and he gets into more trouble than
Christian Bale does which isn't the
entire premise of the movie ultimately
the point of this movie is you watch
Christian Bale's life just fall apart
that's it it's what you do he's gonna
like a guy works hard sucks to be him
cuz it's not gonna work out for him and
no it didn't oh hey here's another
scenario maybe no didn't work out from
there either and let's just watch his
world crumble and it is Bryan Manor damn
it for some people out there
I've been urged to make excuses for this
movie be like oh the directing was good
the camerawork was good the acting was
great the acting was really good if not
great this movie was like j.edgar good
director good actors good premise it
should all work out right but in the end
you're watching the movie going this
movie should be more interesting and it
actually is however the biggest strength
this movie has going for it Woody
Harrelson for sure what do you Harrelson
Tong screen in this movie it's
discomfort to an insane degree but
you're engaged you're like holy
conflict anything that engages you the
audience in a movie these are positive
things Woody Harrelson's character in
this movie is one of those guys you take
your grenade attach it to a fish hook
hang it from his sack blow them away and
know that the world is a better place
without him Woody Harrelson played the
role up beautifully good job Woody
Harrelson good job Christian Bale
good job Casey Affleck good job Willem
Dafoe good job Forest Whitaker everyone
in the movie did well in the movie that
made me all like yeah I get it life
sucks okay hit me in December yeah this
movies going for an Oscar no doubt will
it get it I don't know it's the Academy
if I actually thought like the Academy
I'd have a completely different show
here movies seem to lack focus but you
know stylistically people are gonna be
like that's the movie it's live okay I
get it that being said this is me and
I'm saying that bores me you want to see
life watch life it's there life is
actually interesting in the end of the
can
Merl work was good the actors were
really good the premise was interesting
enough but the execution was just
unfocused and it feels like it's
unfocused because it's supposed to be
because it's supposed to be
philosophical and that's what
philosophical movies go for when they're
trying to go for an Oscar one is you
j.edgar me I'm gonna junior you I will
say out of the furnace is alright but
you're not gonna remember it in t-minus
a couple days yep already forgot movie
had interesting parts but all in all the
movies not really for me because it's
kind of boring
okay so Jimmy you don't know what you
talking about you watch this movie five
times over you're gonna say it's a
masterpiece
yeah oh my face with that that's
called indoctrination when you have to
watch something over and over and over
again and then you're like well I'm
gonna coming around show someone footage
of baby seals getting clubbed initially
they're gonna be like I don't like that
but if you show it to him over and over
and over again eventually they will be
like you know what it's not as bad as I
initially thought it was because it's a
brainwashing and you shouldn't have to
do that to like movies I said out of the
furnace have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you liked what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]